i will getting married i'm gonna drop
the bomb on your show
i'll probably get i'll probably get in
trouble
i'm getting married and you're invited
dwayne dog the bounty hunter chapman is
getting married
well you know it's not my first rodeo no
this is your last time
during tuesday's episode of the two guys
from hollywood podcast the 68 year old
reality star revealed his plans to tie
the knot with his fiance francie frane
in september we went to the venue picked
it out yesterday looked at it
man it cost a lot to get married so
anyway yes september 2nd the tv
personality hinted at his wedding plans
on instagram last week posting this snap
of his bride-to-be alongside the caption
quote i love you and soon be proving
that beyond a shadow of a doubt
he first revealed his relationship with
francie a 52 year old rancher from
colorado back in march 2020. they began
dating nearly 10 months after his wife
beth chapman passed away in june 2019.
she had been diagnosed with stage two
throat cancer in 2017. francie also lost
her late husband bob to cancer
francie's husband passed away over three
years ago
passed away over two years ago and you
know i i felt very bad about even
wanting to have someone else after beth
and then when i went to again the bible
in genesis and found out how adam got
eve as i was going to find the exact
story i saw the scripture that says
god's god does not want a man to be
alone that he knows we need a companion
whether we're man or woman the couple
got engaged in may 2020 and the
lovebirds opened up to e.t about the
moment he popped the question
i got down on one knee and said francie
frank will you marry me i said listen
when i get down then i want you to
get down too on your knee and help me
back up
right
like you i'm getting down so are you
mama
and so i got down and she's like
standing there i was crying and nervous
and you did she didn't even pull me back
up i had to limp up
that's not true you're exaggerating
whatever he did a great job and it was
really romantic how's your family
because you you just got engaged to dog
the bounty hunter so what was the
reaction of your family i didn't tell
anyone
that we were seeing each other i
wouldn't go anywhere in public with him
there's a couple of restaurants in the
town he lives in
that know him really well and so i would
only go to those two places and meet him
because i didn't want anyone to see me
in public or be splattered all over some
tabloid and the more time i spent with
him and um
he's amazing the more the long ranger i
became i called my daughter-in-law and i
said i just want you to come meet
somebody that's in my life and so then
she called me and she said you have to
tell me i can't i can't wait
and so i said to her um so i'm dating
dog the bounty hunter she starts
screaming on the phone you're lying
that's not true
i sent her a picture of the two of us
and then she showed it to my son and he
said you guys aren't funny like he
thinks it's this photoshopped
you guys aren't funny so i had them come
over to the house and then he shows up
at the door
and i think my son sat there for like
five minutes and he couldn't even say a
word because he was shell-shocked
and now
they love him my grandson
calls them grandpa dog already they love
him
[Music]
you